[Music]
welcome everyone to
our farm scale composting workshop
our presenter today is jeff andres
chair of yahara pride farms incorporated
he's the board he's out he serves as the
chair on the board of directors
which in this yahara pride farms is a
farm-led not-for-profit organization
working to improve soil and water
quality
thank you jeff so thank you for having
me and thanks to the sponsors for
sponsoring this segment of
of the conference uh once stephanie
first
approached me about speaking um
she was talking about the composting and
sharing some things
with the with the conference and after i
committed she said i needed to talk for
90 minutes
so hopefully i've got enough information
here and
uh and good information that keeps
everybody
energized and and uh
into this program and and uh hopefully
we all can uh
get something out of it uh we've been
doing this for a while
and uh but uh you know
still a lot to learn so um anders barry
ridge farms
is uh i'm in uh the
uh uh would be the
fourth generation um farmers or
third generation fourth generation
moving to the fifth generation
um this picture here on the farm uh
was the the house and the original dairy
barn was built by my grandpa and
in 1913 the land has been in the family
since
excuse me since uh the late
1800s our farm is uh
is located in the ohio watershed and
as uh my bio says uh we uh
i also chair the higher pride farms
farmer-led organization
um with the uh
where we uh try to
[Music]
improve water quality as well soil
health in this region
working directly with the farmers and
and we've been
in existence since 2012
and the organization has had some great
success
our farm is located in the northwestern
part of the
the watershed uh with the state capitol
uh right in the center of the isthmus of
the five lakes
um very good farmland in this area
uh also very uh very
a very uh populated area as well um
vast majority of the farmers are dairy
mostly in the northern part of the the
watershed
southern part of the watershed is more
crop land and more
more maybe some more of the beef and
swine down in that area
andrus berry ridge farms three equal
partners myself
my brother steve and randy and their
families uh milking 500 cows
approximately 400 heifers 1100 acres of
land
grow alfalfa grass soybeans wheat
i guess we also sell genetics uh
registered herd of cows
uh have some high genomic cows um
we've all showed all three families that
showed at the local fairs and the dairy
expo
so uh well-rounded farm
one of the things that we concentrate on
the farm is being good stewards of the
land
we use a lot of cover crops we do a lot
of minimum tillage
our housing of our livestock calves
up to six months are in group pens
we bed with primarily corn stocks ground
corn stouffer
that corn stover is normally chopped
twice before we bale it
so it's not look overly long and stringy
uh it's sized and particle size
you know three to four inches we do use
a little bit of wood shavings with the
calves
heifers that are seven months and older
are then introduced to freestalls
and we are bedding with uh ground corn
cobs and sawdust in those
stalls and then all our lactating cows
are are on sand bedding
six months all the manure is
i should say the manure to six months
and younger and older
manures all the all the manure from
the heifers from baby calves until they
have their first calf
is now being composted on the farm in
one way or another
uh the manure that from the heifers that
are in the freeze stalls
is hauled daily to a local um
um
what am i saying local manure digester
where they harvest the methane out of it
we bring back the separated fiber
and that goes into the composting
process
we have enough liquid storage for six
months for the lactating cows
what is composting and this is a very
basic definition and it's combining
carbon and nitrogen sources together
and decay the deco composition
uh uh of the organic matter
into a simpler form by introducing these
two
two uh sources together and
by the decaying organic materials then
is used for
plant fertilizer it's been around for
centuries
why farm scale composting
number one thing is just drink volumes
and concentrate nutrients
you also kill pathogens and break down
carbon the carbon bedding
and you make nutrients more available to
the growing crops
and one of the reasons you are making it
more available
is by breaking down the carbon bedding
which normally
in some cases takes up nutrients out of
the soil to break it down in the field
can be an alternative way to handle
manure other than liquid
because the composting process uses a
lot of moisture
you can you can use you can take some
higher moisture manures and introduce it
to the composting process
minimizing the amount of liquid storage
one thing that is became very evident in
our research and the work that we've
done here
is that it converts the soluble
phosphorus in manure to a more stable
particulate form that binds to the
carbon in the compost
therefore making it a safer product to
take to the field
when you have runoff events it doesn't
tend to move as quickly off the field
uh manurepo manure composting and
renaults is also an alternative way to
store
and stack manure um utilizing your
headlands
and your fields actually for the storage
versus
a manure pit or a structure
allows a wider window for applying
livestock nutrients back on the field
we got more ability to spread on on
growing crops in the summertime
a lot of times when you spread liquid
manure it's a fall and
and and spring application only a couple
weeks to get it done
compost allows us to get that nutrients
out there
and more often
more days of the year than say liquid
compost has a less less risk to enter
groundwater because of the organic
nitrogen
tends not to move as easy and better
avoids potential water quality issues by
minimizing the risk of runoff
better utilization of nutrients in the
farm system
this is something i learned early on is
now we have all this nutrients that we
have tied up out in our farm field some
are higher than others
and some fields get manure more often
than others in the form of liquid manure
this way we can get manure out to those
fields that don't
for instance if they're highly erodible
we can get manure to those
fields more often in the form of compost
therefore using the higher
fertility fields of the farms to
actually feed the
lower fertility fields in the farm
history of of composting on at barry
ridge farms
the first time i
was approached about composting was our
tenant we have a hog facility that we
rent out
was the summer of 2000 2014.
got a little misprint there um pvp
dv uh was moving through the country at
that time and
they no longer could render
mortalities so they were looking for an
alternative way to dispose of their
mortalities
and they approached me about getting
some corn stock bedding
to make some windrows to
embed the the mortalities in to
to compost them and i said i could do
one thing better i could supply them
with a
all the betting pack manure they wanted
and
therefore um we
started that process and i was amazed
after
a month's worth of time of that
mortality being in that
windrow house how it disappeared with
very minimal
smell ore or attraction of flies
the summer of 2015
we were awarded a sare grant and
managing
summer we were managing summer packed uh
betting pack manure
strictly in the summer
we we received the grant to offset some
costs and
experiment with composting with two
other local farmers
and that was to
to help understand a little bit more
about what we could do
with the composting what were some of
the alternative
um well first of all could we make good
compost
second of all what are the what are some
of the things we could use the compost
for
one of them was uh potentially some
livestock
uh bedding at at some point
at a certain point of the of the process
as well as we moved some compost off the
farm to another farm
that did not have a history of
manure or or compost in their
farming operation in 2017 we received a
community grant to continue composting
and to build we also built a new heifer
facility
in compost shed so the idea of that
grant
was more on the water quality side of
things being involved with uhera pride
and our organization and the community
this area is very concerned with the
five lakes
of the water quality and what comes off
these farm fields mainly in the form of
phosphorus
we were wondering if there was a way we
could
potentially make compost move that
nutrients
to farms that need it and our
our watershed is a perfect example with
the
livestock being in the northern part of
the watershed and very few livestock in
the southern part of the watershed
how could we potentially work together
and move that nutrients from the farm
from those livestock heavy livestock
areas to areas that are not getting
manure and or organic fertilizer
2018 we designed and built a compost
turner
with a local equipment manufacturer or
i should say a fabricator welding shop
that complemented our composting process
and allows us to be much more efficient
2019 we worked with a number of
different carbon sources in our manure
uh we we did a trial with the mmsd the
madison metropolitan sewer district
uh with some of their class a bile
solids
we worked with some with grass and
straw um
betting pack manure separated fiber all
those types of carbon sources
and we did a study as far as how
how how they performed in the composting
process
2020 we started working with local the
local manure digester
to allow us to increase composting to
all our livestock which i said earlier
other than the milk and cows and
what that really did was allowed us to
get a little additional moisture out of
that manure
before we introduced it to uh the
composting process
and now we have all of
our young stock manures being
being treated or you could say being
processed through the compost
system currently we
continue to try other ideas that might
add value to the
agronomic value of compost and
how it performs in the field
again the sarah grant we
the outcomes uh for the idea of it
was to improve the long-term
sustainability of each farm through the
marketing of value-added soil amendments
and moving nutrients
out of the phosphorus impaired watershed
uh
we did that uh with that trial we had
one of the farms that
uh again we hauled the finished compost
to a farm in the southern part of the
watershed that did not have a manure
history
and we had seen some some results there
we also were looking at
the possibilities of using it for
betting
and the the trial included
daily temperature carbon dioxide
accumulation
moisture percentages visual evaluation
of the leachate and runoff and steam
generated and one of the things that we
are learning with the composting
out in the fields on headland stacking
or
field edge is there's very little
leachate
and and that is very important
as far as worrying about contaminating
contaminating groundwater
um it seems like the the compost
when you're turning the compost
regularly it actually
burns up that extra moisture in the
water
in a lot of cases actually draws
moisture out of the ground
as i said we uh we learned in the sarah
grant that at a certain point
in the process three or four weeks in
that the compost
uh was in a state that we thought it
would actually make
pretty decent bedding at that time it
probably was turned four or five times
uh had good pathogen kill and we used it
in our freestyles for our heifers
one of the problems we had though
because we did we only scrape once a day
our
freestyle alleyways we had some issues
with hairy hoof warts with the
with the heifers uh they were drawing a
little bit too much
moisture into the into the freestalls
and seemed like those hairy hoof it's
flourished
um in our facility
at the end of the day uh it didn't work
well for us
uh as far as car cow comfort it was
great i think in a situation where you
had alley scrapers
or a slatted floor i think this could
be a pretty good
potential practice or at a minimum being
able to mix that
with another carbon source as bedding
the community compost grant from 2017 to
was funded and retrieved through the
clean lakes alliance
worked with uw madison on the research
side of things
evaluate the potential runoff of pea
loss on farms during the manure
composting process and the application
to crop
fields this is where we found out that
there was a transition from from
from soluble phosphorus to particulate
phosphorus that binds to the carbon
within the compost
that was something that
we didn't realize prior to this and and
[Music]
we feel is pretty beneficial for the
environments
again we used we also use bedding from
the six months and
younger the corn stalks straw
some wood shavings a little bit of sand
mixed in some of that as well
we were able to
get a little better handle on the
expenses of what it was actually costing
us
at that time to do the composting
process that i'll be sharing later
the outcomes of the growing of the
compost grant the summary
the growing awareness of the spreading
of pack manure and melting snow
is not the best way to manage and use
nutrients in the manure
so the idea of this was could we take
manure off the farm fields
at particularly this time of the year
when people
are needing to get manure off out of the
out of the pens
it's thawing can we put it into a
windrow and turn it into compost rather
than
spreading it out on the fields where it
is
highly
soluble phosphorus would
potentially move with the melting snow
and get into our waterways
we also learned that the compost dries
down saving a lot of
a lot of hauling costs we're generally
seeing
a reduction of anywhere between 40 and
60 percent in volume
we also learned that composting compost
could be spread
on growing crops like alfalfa hay and
through our yield monitors on our
chopper uh where we harvest the
the uh hey we were able to see
a little bit of a yield bump um i was
looking more so to see if we'd see a
yield drag
if we were doing any damage so being
that we've seen a little bit of a yield
bump and we could detect it
with our our own yield monitoring i felt
pretty good about that nutrients being
used out in the
hay fields the other concern when you
put it on hay fields is you want
the pathogens to be reduced you don't
want to be re-harvesting
pathogens especially pathogens that
potentially could lead to herd diseases
like yoni's
again the compost was more flexible for
land application
and now we have the potential of selling
off the farm
our some of our excess nutrients
headland stacking a convenient way to
start composting
you could you could headline stack this
time of the year
another way of being uh uh
minima by bit another way to minimize
the risk of
nutrients leaving the field and it would
just be a matter of bringing in
the compost turner to aerate that
that headland stack or that windrow on
the edge of the field
these areas when we sight them we're
usually looking for areas that
maybe are high traffic areas that don't
have the yield potential
therefore you're not necessarily taking
land out of production that
that could be a net gain to your farm
operation
or your your feed needs
the compost turner uh obviously you need
to introduce that
oxygen and liquidate the
waste gases uh to allow the composting
and
speedy decompress sensation the
composting process how are we going
about composting on our farm
as of as of today
and i guess the the
main thing is when we compost on our
farm we do
do it two ways we do some of it on a
controlled environment under a roof
and we do some on an outside pad
cement pad where we
uh are a little bit more exposed to the
elements of of
uh of the weather and
uh to the picture to the right i got
actually got a caught a bald eagle
uh checking in on what we were doing uh
one day
uh i thought it was kind of kind of
interesting
uh he must have seen it from a bird's
eye view and had to
take a closer look so there is there is
interest in composting
out there and uh
even this fellow was willing to check it
out
where can you compost so
the
the uh compost is
we are doing it under a roof uh
and that roof is uh um
not cemented underneath it's a three
foot a clay
base that was built for this
specifically
nrcs approved
and then we also do an outside
composting
pad uh that we uh
have a little bit more more material
than what we
can do under the roof that's our our
overflow
both work well uh both have some
challenges
i do see a couple questions here uh
first one being uh any permits needed
uh for in and
nutrient management plan
and um
no we we are actually allowed to do
up to 4 500 yards
one particular site if you do it on
headline stacking
based off of nrcs rules
and was there any analysis done of the
microbe
composition of the finished compost
we have not yet we do have some
i do have some tests of trace elements
within the
compost on the fertility side
moving forward here's another example of
where you compost though some of these
trials we were doing out in the fields
here's a example of field edge
windrows that were in the field and
if you look at the fields there is no in
the field here in the grass growing next
to the
compost you're not seeing any signs of
leeching or burning of the grass
that's coming out of these wind rolls
the types of manure that we are now
putting into our compost
on the left hand side we've got the
freestall scraping
so that's the manure that we are
actually taking to the digester right
now
that's you can see it's got a a little
bit of a
slump to it it's not straight water by
no means
we can handle it with the the tractor
loader
bucket we can load it with the tractor
loader we it's not pumpable
so it actually works quite well for
the the digester manure
we're actually taking a fair amount of
methane capability within that manure
because it
is a little on the thicker side that
helps offset some of the
cost of transportation to make it
uh viable betting pack
manure that's our main carbon source
that's where
a lot of the energy is coming from to
make the compost
here's a picture of the separated solids
notice that's that's very stackable
that's the
the separated um solids parts that come
out of the
the liquid that goes to the to the
digester
when we build our windrows we are
loading the different types of manure
and what you're seeing here in this
picture is um
the tractor or the spreader that we load
this
uh this um
manure into is kind of a multi-faceted
machine
for us that that same spreader is used
to haul
the manure the scrapings to the digester
on a daily basis
hauls the fiber back also builds
helps us build the windrows as well as
spread the finished compost
so we're this machine we're getting a
lot of use out of
on our farm very important when you add
the extra steps
to the composting process
so that you have that you're not adding
a lot of equipment cost that's not
being used
the the loader then
we load the three different the two
ingredients system we're really only
using two ingredients here now
is the bedding pack manure um
and the separated solids after that's
loaded
in the spreader the mix we are using
right now
is three parts fiber one part
uh bedding pack we then build our
windrows
so you can see this we back the spreader
up to
the windrow open the back gate and as we
spread it it makes this perfect pyramid
uh this this this uh
that is uh basically what we want
to make a good compost windrower
or to start the composting process uh we
get a good mix of these two materials
uh early on we don't have to turn it to
get this mix
usually we are building a windrow week
we are
finishing a win roll week based on the
amount of manure we have
and so this this
win roll will sit for about a week
before it gets actually turned with the
compost turner
once we start the compost turning uh
process
uh we'll turn uh
usually weekly we will hit that sweet
sweet spot of when we're got good
temperatures we'll
turn five times in the matter of uh
two weeks process to maintain that 135
degree temperature at all times
here's a site of the finished compost
we've got
compost outside here you can notice the
strength the
the color the size of
the reduction obviously
in volume uh and then under the shed
roof here or the compost building
the windrow farthest to the right is the
one that's the closest to finish
and the other two are
you know got a couple weeks to go yet
transportation and staging of the
compost so
our farm we we have land that varies
from two miles to
ten miles from the home farm so
we have to transport some of this
compost some
a fair distance and when we do it we try
to
load it as efficiently and haul it as
efficiently as possible
haul it to the field it's going to get
spread on so when we get into that field
to spread it
that we're not wasting any time that
we're basically loading and spreading
and making full um
efficiency of both the loader and the
spreader
when we go into the spreading process
but here
on the right hand side you can see what
a windrow looks like
in the field this time of the year
scrape away the snow so we can put it on
basically on top of the dirt and in our
situation we don't take it
to uh to a finished
compost state like you'd put in a bag so
it will
heat a little bit yet out in the field
and
i guess you could say it can condition
it or
or just do the last finishing in the
field
and then the spreading uh here you see
the same machine
we put spinners into the under the back
of the spreader
able to spread up to about 80 feet
real consistently with this spreader and
this
picture shows us spreading it on grassy
hayfield
and the biggest thing that i've noticed
when we're spreading compost
is that you don't paint the ground like
you do with
when you're typically hauling a manure
with like a slinger spreader or um
or a box spreader it's just you don't
have the you don't
have the volume to do that but yet
you're getting
probably as much nutrients if not more
onto the field
and being a lot less visible
visible for the byspan
the public as well any questions here or
some questions to catch up on
okay how do your costs compare to the
traditional soil management so
one of what we're finding is here is
that we're actually
we're going to get into it a little bit
later but our
nutrients
i can haul compost to the field
much further than i can liquid manure
and to get the value out of it so
for instance a load of compost on a
straight truck could
probably worth about 600 bucks
in fertilizer value the
same payload and liquid might be about
to 80 a load so therefore
i can haul that nutrients further before
the value of that of that nutrients is
gone
we also are seeing reduction in the
amount of fertilizer
we have to put on to the purchase and
put onto fields because we are used
better utilizing the nutrients within
the farm system
the challenges with winter composting is
moisture
and that's one of the questions here as
well
and we tend to
to in our our setup here is we try to go
in with drier
carbon sources to begin with if if
possible um
art of compost generally runs higher in
moisture
in the winter months um there are
some uh opportunities out there
to put aeration under the windrows if
you want to spend the money
we turn more often in the winter
we also try to
do it in a way that
the moisture leaves the pile so i don't
like to turn on days where
where it's cold real cold
if we don't have to uh just so that
moisture gets away from
the pile
uh the npk analysis of the finished
compost i'm going to share that a little
bit later we have some variation we have
some carbon nitrogen ratios
that i'll be sharing later as and as
well
so
now the economics
this is probably
this is something that's really
important to understand
and we we performed
some economics early on with the
community composting grant
i went through this winter and and i've
kind of updated that
to what we're able to be how those
economics are working for our farm right
now
um now that we've ramped up our our
production
so if you look at the cost analysis of
traditional manure handling
we have here we have a
chart or a cost breakdown in a couple
different categories i'm going to start
with the top one here
so in this cost analysis we've actually
took the value of the
of the betting stock or the betting that
was going into the manure
and the amount of bales and so forth
and in this case it showed it was 504
uh dollars in value that's probably
going up a little bit
this particular cost analysis was done
on basically 467 cubic yards of
betting pack manure coming out of the
facility
we go down to the actual cost of
scraping
and cleaning the barn
and the labor
and then we look at the total cost of
the manure
so the total cost to clean out that barn
and
build the windrows in this situation
uh or we're just cleaning the barn i
should say in this cost
scenario and hauling it directly to the
field so the total cost was over three
thousand dollars
um but the cost per yard
was six dollars and 51 cents so that's
what it would typically cost
to in our if we would be hauling this
cleaning this barn and hauling it
directly to the field
and that's more of the typical way of of
handling
betting pack manure if we add the com
compost process to it you know we're
going to we've got the turning expense
we have there we should actually have
the facility cost
um so um
and then we have the cost of the turner
in the top box here
loading the compost at the barn again
to move it further out reloading the
compost on the tubby spreader for
spreading
that's what we figured the cost there
total cost
the total cost to produce haul and
spread the compost it was like forty
eight
hundred and seventy seven dollars you
noticed on the page before it was right
around three thousand dollars just to
haul it directly to the field
if we take that on a on a
on a per cubic yard uh
price to spread the compost to the field
at that time we were estimating it was
costing
21.77 cents per cubic
yard to
to haul or to make and haul that compost
on the field if we were to load that
compost and not take it to the field and
just sell it
we were figuring the cost net cost of
production would be about 18.97
so 1897 if we convert that to
a per ton cost because most of
our analysis are done on a per ton
basis for when you send your compost off
to get an
analysis on it comes back the nitrogen
the phosphorus and
the potassium are tabulated
as a per ton basis being that a yard of
compost doesn't weigh a ton
it comes out to 32.31 cents per
s per ton spread on the field under this
scenario
if we were to just uh sell it
uh and put it on a truck it would be 29
a ton for those costs
so those those costs have to be made up
somewhere
so the compost uh comparison direct call
to the field versus finishing compost
we are seeing about six dollars right
now
six dollars and fifty cents a yard to
convert the manure into compost
or ten dollars a ton for the finished
compost mold it's costing ten dollars
more a ton
to do it if rather than just haul it
directly to the field
now some cost analysis based off of
where we are today now
and now as of now as you
the shed the interest appreciation and
principle i figured i based this all on
a per yard basis i figured it was 244.
uh building the compost windrow that
would be
as i showed you in the pictures earlier
the loading of the manure the different
ingredients onto the spreader and
running it back out
i figure it's about two dollars per yard
turning the compost
eight times two dollars and fifty
cents per yard loading the finished
compost for field spreading
or sale uh we have we're a little more
efficient with that now we got a bigger
loader
uh a dollar fifty per yard so
our totals as of what we're making now
is about eight dollars and 44 cents per
yard
to make it into compost
just to make the compost and load it the
cost of spreading the compost we figure
up to two miles which is three dollars
and eighty cents per yard
so therefore we've got it delivered and
spread to the field
for twelve dollars and twenty four cents
a yard
or 18.83 cents per
per finish ton
cost analysis then versus now we're
looking at 32 tons
uh 32.31 cents a ton
spread on the field uh
versus the 18.44
per ton for now so here we're
here we are looking at a value of the
compost that's
the questionnaire what are the np's and
k's uh
in this situation this uh this was done
in 2016
um on a per ton basis on this particular
analysis
we figured the value of the nitrogen uh
was 12.87
cents per ton the phosphorus was 6.92
cents
per ton the potassium was 7.99 per ton
the sulfur was a dollar 51 a ton
calcium was 5.05 per ton
magnesium was 350 per ton
and then if you take all the others less
significant numbers for
analysis but it's still important to the
crop
the boron the zinc the copper the
magnesium
the maliburum um
the total value of that compost comes up
to 41.79 per ton
so there's still some extra value above
and beyond the production
for that that particular compost
there's a difference in compost um
now here we've been playing around with
different feedstocks
going into the compost some are create
higher compost
numbers than others moisture has a lot
to do with it
uh if you look at the upper left-hand
column here we've got a compost sample
that runs 69
moisture that's a little on the high
side you're looking at the nitrogen
at nine nine point three nine
per ton uh total phosphorus at eight
point five
four ton potassium 9.94
and sulfur 1.79
you take the sample in the lower right
hand corner
now this is 41 percent moisture
considerably drier
all of a sudden with the feedstock in
this particular case
we've got nitrogen at 3181
we got phosphorus at 2846
and potassium at 56 16
and sulfur at 783
there's a couple things that could play
into this
the carbon the nitrogen ratio obviously
the moisture is number one
the carbon the nitrogen ratio of the
first sample was 14 to 1.
the carbon and nitrogen ratio of the
second sample is 11 the one
so the one in the lower right
is more finished and drier
uh the feedstock going into it might
have been higher in
np and k to begin with as well so that's
why now
in our um recipe we've kind of got it
zeroed in to just that
three three to one ratio then we uh
we got a more consistent product coming
out
um that also has been made better
because we are making our windrows with
the
with the spreader uh versus a loader
tractor
we have a much better job of having a
consistent windrow from end to end
we don't have that inconsistency of
maybe
we have a hot spot in in the middle of
the wind roll where
it got a little bit more of this uh
higher
higher uh uh fertility feedstock to
begin with and
all of a sudden we've pulled a sample
out of out of that area so
we're more we're more consistent now
than than we were previous
compost analysis is by the season so
what this
is is what is how are
our compost uh testing by the season
the one on the left i think as i break
down him
you have the average moisture the actual
heist
so this is a series of samples we sample
every windrow
so we took the high windrow and the low
windrow and then we have an average
so if you got the moisture content
you know the average is 56. uh
organic matter 24 ph 9.5
our ph is seem to run a little bit
higher even on the real finished compost
and then you can see the average is for
the n p and k
um and then on the bottom you can see
uh how the nitrogen and ammonium and
uh the organic end and so forth and the
carbon to nitrogen ratio
spring now the spring compost would be
the compost that would be being made
right now
in the months of january and february uh
the summer compost would be basically
the compost that's being made
in early spring and then the fall
compost would be
the compost that's being made
in the summer and the winter compost
would be
what is being started in the fall
if you look at the summer compost
the moisture goes down six percent
have a little bit higher
numbers as far as the potassium nitrogen
is down
[Music]
this particular case the phosphorus is
is a little bit lower but then that
spring compost we had
and that we had a ingredient in that uh
high one that really pushed the
phosphorus so that one's a little
a little out of whack there so
um again then on the bottom in this
particular case
uh we didn't have uh as much of a
breakdown on the organic and
but the total carbon or the carbon
nitrogen ratio was 13.26
for an average
we take the fall now here here is that
that material that's being made in the
summer notice it's drier on an average
we had a high of 56 and a low of 38
if you look at those numbers
we have a variation there
ph again is still still up there
nitrogen on the high one was pretty high
the phosphorus is is relatively high on
the high one as well but uh
um if if we can duplicate that
in a mix now we got something that we
can justify hauling even further out
than
than uh your standard compost so
there are ways to to spice this compost
up a little bit
to have a little more value in it based
on the feedstock that's going in it and
how we treat it
again on the bottom carbon and nitrogen
ratio on these we're averaging 11.47
now winter
there's the moisture there's our big
that's my biggest challenge is the
winter
compost is dealing with the moisture and
not having that pile go stagnant on us
and 68 is getting up there
i always kind of fall on the
rule of thumb that making compost is
like making silage
um if it's too wet it
doesn't work well in a ration if it's
too dry it doesn't work well in the
ration
so if you can keep it somewhere between
55 and 65 you've got a really good
working range here you can see the
averages on that
you know our high had a had a carbon to
nitrogen ratio at the bottom of 16.36
that's probably not finished real well
that was 72 percent moisture that's
probably why
the one that was 61 had a carbon to
nitrogen ratio of 11.2 that's more
acceptable
and you know the average was 13.83
now that was a lot of stuff do we have
any questions on that
okay
okay so are the carbon nitrogen nitrogen
ratios from
a start or end of the compost process so
carbon and nitrogen ratios on ours are
usually start around
at 30 30 to 1 when it's fresh
made in the windrow
we always kind of figure the way we're
using it out in the field not
necessarily selling it as
a class a compost anytime it's below
15 to 1 i feel
it's time to move it out um we're
getting the value of the
the uh pathogen kill at that point
we have a pretty good carbon number
there um the shrink is there
um and we just
i just don't want to
put any more time and money into it than
i absolutely have to
if i was to sell the compost
we would probably then have to spend a
little more time
with it the ideal carbon and nitrogen
ratio
is uh from what i understand is anywhere
15 and lower it's very hard to get
carbon to nitrogen ratios
uh under 10. so when she's getting down
to that 11 range you've got a pretty
good
finished compost that's when it's
really black in color the texture is his
uh particle size is real
small it's got that real earthy smell
um those are what that's
to me is some of the best uh based on
the visual and the smell
can you explain about the compost turner
i would like to know what model you use
to have it
custom built so our compost turner
that we built um uh
it is it does a complete turn
of the of the compost um
we back into the compost it's there uh
there's a beater that uh flings it up in
the air and onto a conveyor belt that
re-stacks it
and this uh this turner i i can't talk
too much about it
i'm i'm in the process of potentially
patenting this
turner um but uh it's been working quite
well for us
and i think part of the reason we're
able to do some of the things we're
doing
uh in a timely fashion is because of the
turner itself
the question here is i don't see any
line in your cost analysis for the cost
of
not turning soluble n and p
into the insoluble or into other words
taking organic and
and pee and turning it into organic
therefore making it
insoluble until root
extratulates
call for it real value
yeah and that one um that's true
but how do you come up with that number
that's one of
some of the things that we still have to
that i don't quite understand yet
maybe some of the people that are
listening in maybe have some answers
because
uh there are definitely some hidden
values there that we are
do not label in our numbers
a question here is i came in late what
do you see as a carbon
what what do you oh what do you use as a
carbon source to manage your
carbon and nitrogen ratio um
our main carbon source in our in our
compost here
is corn stocks um actually betting pack
manure
taken right out of the out of the out of
the barn
and with either straw or or corn stalks
has the almost the perfect nitrogen
carbon and nitrogen ratio to start the
composting process
all right caught up on the questions
and we're going to move on to the next
section we got another one
uh what equipment used to measure the
temperature for
legal compost
i am just taking temperatures at this
point right now
um we'll probably have to invest into
some more sophisticated equipment if we
are actually going to start marketing
compost
but i'm pretty much falling back on
temperatures
and watching temperatures to
make sure we're turning in a timely
fashion and then
when temperatures tend to drop and the
carbon and nitrogen ratio
goes down that's what we're basing
our our time to move it out
or finish turning
conclusion
that's what i was saying composting
unknown value
and here's a list of things that we
don't know
and i have a hard time putting a handle
on
what is the value of adding compost to
the soil for soil health purposes
so we know by taking compost to the
southern part of the watershed
back in 2015 and 16
the farmer applied four ton to the
to the acre at that time a one-time
application
the fir from that point the following
years moving forward up until this year
even he's seen a yield bump in the area
within the field where he spread the
compost
in soybeans and corn both were you know
pushing
close to 10 bushels to the acre
at the high he was still seeing a couple
bushels this year
so there's something going on in the
soil there by introducing compost and
it's not just the
the the np and k
that carbon and and organic matter and
and the biology of that compost is doing
something
uh significant and i'm open
to anybody that has any more information
on that
uh that could share with us and then
it's definitely something we'll be
working on here closely uh with trials
that come to see if we can
um actually figure out what's happening
what is the value of the additional
carbon from the compost
add it back to the soil when you spread
it
how do we put a number on that value and
what is the value of the organic makeup
of the compost when compared to
conventional fertilizer
obviously this farmer was using
he was getting good yields we introduced
the compost to it
and within a year's time you had
even better yields so there's definitely
something going on there
better utilization of nutrients in the
farm system i talked about that earlier
how do we how do we uh utilize
best utilize the nutrients that we have
paid for on the farm
and sharing it from field to field
convenience of the value of moving and
staging manure to farm fields before
hauling
this time of the year we don't i
shouldn't say we don't have a lot to do
but we have
we have a little more time to actually
stage that manure
get it to those fields taking the
transportation part out of the equation
at the time when you need to be out
there spreading
the ability to manage betting pack
manure all months of the year
that was a challenge for us you know
uh when you have bedding pack barns that
need to be cleaned out in the summer
months
um you you're limited on fields where
you can spread it
you can't spread it on hay fields uh
you'll smother out the alfalfa or the
grass
you take the potential of reharvesting
it again
therefore composting and breaking it
down
allows us to do that select days for
hauling
that are best for the field conditions
there's a value there
uh you're not out there compacting the
soil
uh your can pick your dry days
um or or days when the
uh the weather is is uh better for
spreading uh manure or nutrients out on
the field
spreading manure compost on fields that
won't have received manure
there are fields on our farm because of
the
landscape that we cannot put liquid
manure on
uh it just it's too hard we do most of
our liquid manure
application in the form of drag lines
you get on some of these steep fields
and it's hard to pull a hose on a
steep field with their high slopes it
makes some challenges
problems with potential of kinking hoses
and things like that
allows for redistribution of nutrients
within the farm
system to all fields as i talked about
cons of composting costs costs more to
compost
you know even though it come only
doesn't look significant but 6.50 cents
a yard or 10
a ton um doesn't
seem all that big but if you put four
ton to the acre on
all of a sudden you're looking at forty
dollars an acre more
uh to to put that nutrients out in that
field that same nutrients granted it's
in a different form
probably more usable those are the types
of things that we
have to be able to offset the expenses
of the production some way somehow to
justify
the extra time and the commitment uh
[Music]
uh for for the composting process
time time commitment is is big it takes
time
to to stage this manure takes time to
make the wind rolls takes time to turn
the manure
some farms don't have that time that
labor force
some do the nice thing about the turner
that we are
working with here on our farm is it's
completely mobile
some of our trials we're doing working
with
with farmers uh we uh we're as far as
five miles away we're able to
move that turner with the tractor and a
minimum amount of time
to turn their wind roads so there's a
potential that
that compost turning and
making could be could be
a custom custom applica
application or a custom customly done
by somebody that wants to move from farm
to farm
if it picks up in in popularity
equipment and facility costs
the equipment isn't cheap the spreader
isn't cheap the turner isn't cheap
we have we we have uh
most of our manures being composted
under the the roof the
more of a controlled environment i
believe it's that's
well worth it um the consistency of the
product coming out
uh saves in time potentially if you have
a
a windrow that goes dormant on you
halfway through the process of being
outside if you get a heavy rain or
something
then you you gotta either introduce more
carbon to it or you have to wait it out
to
get revitalize that compost windrow
so it takes a little bit of that risk
away with the facility cost
lack of equipment and availability um
when i started looking
for compost turners that would work well
in our
in our shed uh that's what brought me to
the idea
of building a compost turner i think
uh we we
the uh the equipment uh that is needed
at a farm level
is uh is
is maybe not there uh yet
or maybe it's coming um seems like most
of the compost turners that were out
there
were either too big for what we wanted
or or too small weather challenges in
this region
northern you know we're we're in the
southern part of wisconsin
we have some cold weather in january and
february as we
well recognize here coming out of the
the cool weather we had here recently uh
those challenges
um add that adds a challenge to the
compost
uh process especially when you're in the
deep freeze
i don't like the turn if i don't have to
in those
those uh temperatures because it seems
to thin out my
my uh bug count or my bacteria count the
good bacteria
also i'm turning frost and moisture back
into the windrow
that normally would be volatile up in
the air
ability to dissipate the moisture into
the compost in the winter months just
talked about that
getting that moisture to actually leave
that wind roll
if we're going to do this in a large
scale um
we may have to introduce some form of
ventilation or air in the floor systems
to potentially drive that moisture away
from the windrows
at this time of the year what we have
learned
uh we have learned that we have the
ability to make a high quality compost
product
um you know we've we've got some compost
that's
very high value um depending upon the
feedstocks
it's a matter of zeroing in on your
recipes and your
your sources to to make a consistent
product
uh compost process works well if you
have raw
products and multiple types of manure uh
we are
we have proven that uh we've even taken
it one step further as i've
talked to you earlier about with some of
the class a product coming out of the
madison metropolitan sewer district
can shrink manure volume considerably by
composting
i think we've seen anywhere from 40 to
60 percent
in volume uh reductions uh that's huge
when
you gotta offset the costs of the extra
time
and investment to make compost can make
nutrients much more available and stable
for composting
with composting versus conventional pack
manure
i think we've seen that in our what
we've seen out in the field with our
yields
we've we definitely know that if you
haul
a lot of uh straw and
and corn stock uh
carbon based fresh manure out in the
field that it
can sometimes suppress
the uh the yield or or potential of that
crop that year
just because of the tying up the
nutrients that's in the soil
vibrate to break down the carbon in that
manure
we can spread product on growing crops
alfalfa grass we even did some on
soybeans last year
for a farmer that's that's a positive
can transport nutrients further in the
form of compost
before the economic value of the product
becomes a net
loss you can manage processed manure on
field edges
it's perfectly legal to do that um
it's a good way of uh saving some time
and
at the hauling time we can dispose of
livestock mortalities i started out my
presentation and that's
where we learned what composting was
all about so to speak was working with
with the
mortalities and how it shrinks how we're
able to
decompose that that mortality and that
that one roll of manure and and
and shrink shrink that manure at the
same time
uh pretty uh safe and
efficient way to limit yourself to
exposure to
other diseases and pathogens with the
with the rendering truck coming onto the
farm
can reintroduce carbon back to the farm
fields in the form of compost
that's that's a given
can mix other things with compost um you
know we can
we can potentially add lime uh wallboard
municipal mixes that
that is important that spreader that i i
have here
and showed you on the screen has the
potential of spreading lime
um you could mix lime with your compost
on a field that you wanted to seed into
alfalfa
and and spread the lime and the
compost at the same time a lot of wall
board down in this area with the amount
of housing and
building in in this region the southern
part of the state has a lot of gypsum
in it um some value in that
in our watershed here the municipal
uh municipality sewer districts they're
they're they've got a challenge they
they're actually competing with farmers
for land to spread the human waste on
there might be a potential to commingle
our products
to make a product that works uh
for for the farmers and and work
together
could that's a possibility it may not
fit the organic world but it might fit
the conventional systems convert soluble
phosphorus from raw manure into more
stable particulate form
through the composting process we've
we've
seen that in our work with the
with the university and and the
community grant
what we need to learn how does
finnish complain compost interact with
the soil
um i guess that's something that i would
really
like to get into more depth now and
understand
what's happening in those farm fields
when we put that compost out there
can compost be another saleable
commodity coming off the farm
and off our waste stream so
if if we if we can
and i and my i have a
enough um
experience with this now that i feel
that it can be
um i think it i think that would be
very very important for the future of of
the livestock industry if we can
uh somehow make a product coming off of
their waste stream that could
form an another form of income
there's farms out there that need that
organic fertilizer and they need those
nutrients
so how much compost do we need to put on
per acre
to to get the benefits of this
that you need in the soil uh
that kick so to speak uh
to get that kick uh is it four ton
is it maybe a thousand pounds if it's
a thousand pounds i've got all kinds of
compost that i can
share with people if i need to continue
putting
four to five ton on my hay fields then
maybe
maybe i don't we can pool resources to
engage a larger number of farmers
i mean can we do this um i'm starting to
think we can
um it's just a matter of how does that
all work and
how can we work together to do that
how much composters need to apply to be
applied to obtain maximum soil health
benefits i just touched on that a little
a little bit early but uh what is that
um what is that magic number
how much compost do we need to apply per
acre to get the full value of compost
working in the soil
can the rest be marketed and that's
that's the bottom line
why manage manure by composting
any size farm can successfully compost
um that's that's been proven
better utilization of nutrients in the
farm system i've talked about that a
number of times
mobilization of nutrients needed in
specific fields
um you know i do my own snap plus
nutrient management planning and i got a
pretty good handle on
fields that are low on phosphorus and
need phosphorus
i try to build those fields within the
system with the phosphorus that's in the
compost
get the nutrients to the fields that are
highly erodible
tend to be the hardest ones to get the
minor spreader to or the drag line to
some of them fields aren't getting corn
that is often so it's hard to
hit them on a regular basis
uh liquid manure storage costly to store
hauling comes because of the volume
um no no secret in that i mean
um manure structures are
costing more and more a year every year
that goes by to build
um and how can we shrink that
again to shrink that volume of manure uh
so that
when we put wheels under it that it's
more concentrated and
and more
condensed so that we can
move it move it out more efficiently and
further
allowed to headland stack and stage
compost on fields in winter months
when liquid manure can't be spread um
those headlands don't aren't costing you
much more than the taxes in the winter
months for them to be sitting there
on the farm field might as well make use
of them
some of these field edge
you know tree line areas they're not
growing the best crops to begin with
maybe we should be
utilizing them for staging our nutrients
out there earlier
pathogen removal another one how do we
put a value on that but
but uh that is the reason why
that we should be composting kills kills
a number
of pathogens uh allows
for spreading on growing crops and then
reduces that potential
for these disease spreading example
would be like yoni's
our herd is pretty well eradicated uh
yoni's
and we've been able to do it with with
good management practices
and i guess we're at the point here
where we can field a few more questions
and
maybe even have some dialogue so
uh so the first question in other words
what is the benefit or not
containing the groundwater and surface
waters with p
and n would you not agree that it is
priceless
yeah i agree it's it is uh but
even though it's priceless somebody has
to pay for it
there's a cost in it so um
you know my farm this is there's no
doubt about it i am spending more money
on our farm making compost
right now than if i was directly hauling
that material to the field
and so to
ask other farmers to do the same thing
we really got to know the benefits and
the values of those things
so we can justify
making the change and
the things that lead to um
better soil health and better
utilization of nitrogen
and and the nutrients within the compost
all those things
are wind winds i always call them the
wind winds and when you win for the
environment and you win for the farmer's
bottom line
those are easy to adopt and adapt to
but the ones that that are just
flat costs to the farm them are harder
to sell
would not an easy justification for
added costs
be the simple fact that 70 of your non
composted
nitrogen from the manure is leaching to
the groundwater
only 30 percent plant utilization 100 of
nitrogen in your compost is being
utilized by the plant huge
i would agree um being able to have that
in organic form
slow release and tying it up i think
is big those are things those are the
messages that need to be told with this
what is the width length and height
of your windrows our windrows generally
start out at about six to seven feet
high
the width at the bottom is about 12 feet
generally when they're done more more on
the finished side
they shrink down to about three feet um
and in some cases we actually combine
windrolls
to keep to keep the composting uh
process going a little longer
is there any thought to compost some
or slash all the milk and cow manure
um the challenge that i would have with
the milk and cow manure
is is the excess water that's in the
liquid
manure from a dairy cow dairy cow drinks
a lot of water
so she's she's putting out a lot of a
lot of moisture in her manure
um there are
some facilities in europe where they're
where they are
taking a liquid manure and and
high volumes of water in it and are
composting it
i not up to speed on them i don't
know that particularly
the answer um but i know
the more things that i have to build and
add to the farm the more costs
that's going to be for for for doing it
so
um if we can do it someday i'm sure we
will
uh it's a work in our case it's a
working progress
what effect does your composting process
have on greenhouse gas emissions
well that's a good question um so
there's no lie
there we're emitting some greenhouse
grasses through
gases through the composting process um
now there is the potential
of adding some some things to the
compost
that could alleviate some of that i'm
going to be working with some people
moving forward on that idea i can't
reveal what the product is yet but we
are going to be testing that
so any time we can keep some nighter
excess nitrogen into that compost
um that should help with the vaultation
of
greenhouse gases what is the size of
your building and how many yards and
tons can it handle
so our building is 65
for 60 by 220. i have four windrows in
there
at a time i always figure a windrow per
foot approximately a ton
[Music]
a ton half a third of a ton per foot
the building is actually quite high it's
i think it's 16 or 17 feet to the truss
height
that gives us plenty of room to
use the spreader open the end gate in
there and not hit the
bottom of the trusses
[Music]
do
you